what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are picking up with
Christopher priests inaugural run of the
Justice League with the people versus
the Justice League and you guys you got
to be are with me in this video because
I have food poisoning so I am I guess my
better judgment I am recording this
while I am in no position to record
anything but the funny thing about
Christopher priest writing is it can be
difficult to follow people who are
reading death stroke rebirth you guys
know what I'm talking about like like
history priests will jump from the past
to the present now the good thing is
that in this story he doesn't do that
it's a pretty linear chronology and in
truth this actually is really more of a
like a 1998 feel for a black panther
than it is for the Justice League just
because of the fact that during that run
each comic was really more of like a
standalone story but it fed into the
greater whole of like the full story arc
so in truth you could reach eeeh you
could read each one of these comic books
individually because each one doesn't
really build on the last it does to a
degree but not in the extreme it's just
like one or two plot points they kind of
continue on to the next thing so it's
pretty easy to follow and pretty
straightforward but this story is
basically designed to answer the
question in DC rebirth Batman has a team
in Detective Comics and Batman has his
own events of his own solo series and
Batman's leading his own Justice League
of America team and Batman is part of
Trinity with Superman and Wonder Woman
with all these things that Batman has
going on what happens when it all
catches up to him and what happens when
Batman fails and that's what's so cool
about this because remember while
Superman is probably the most powerful
member of the Justice League going back
and forth abit between like Green
Lantern and Wonder Woman depending on
who's writing the story by and large
Batman's basically considered to be the
leader of the team just because of the
fact that he's like the brains behind
the operation and so the funny thing is
that within you know in this particular
segment over the course of four days
Batman's had about three hours of sleep
you know so I'm sorry over about a three
day span I said about four hours of
sleep so at this point like he's
literally running on fumes and the issue
is that once he gets to the Justice
League Watchtower it's not some massive
event that's taking place here that's a
cool thing about Christopher freeze
riding in this story it's not like a
planet threatening event I mean on the
whole with the Justice League we usually
expect it to be just because of the fact
that it's the Justice League but the
cool thing is that it kind of grounds
the team a bit instead they're dealing
with more small-time threats things like
construction accidents and you know
earthquakes and different things along
those lines because it's one of the
things is tint that tends to sort of get
lost in the Justice League storytelling
from various writers is people tend to
lose perspective that like the Justice
League
it's basically a humanitarian team now
of course the funny thing about this is
that this takes place really has like
three events going on at the same time
the first is that there's essentially
like a massive earthquake or something
like that set off this tsunami more or
less the other thing is that there's a
whole bunch of ships that are traveling
towards Earth and the third thing is
that there is a hostage situation with
regards to like a handful of nuns in a
religious fundamentalist group now the
cool thing about this is that the
characters are basically basically
playing roles that we wouldn't normally
see them play for example Aquaman is
like a bus driver Wonder Woman is just
kind of like a person who's operating is
like a mail delivery Foca a male
delivery individual and then of course
you know Batman's kind of you know
watching everything unfold / tuning to
be a bus passenger or the reason why
they're in this position is because
they're recounting more or less they're
going through and they're looking around
and you know trying to figure out what's
what's going on here now again this is
not normal this is not something we
usually see and that's why you kind of
have to take the Christopher Prius
Justice League run with like okay this
is sort of a new direction for the team
because normally it would just bust in
right they would just come flying in and
they would just be like alright this
little things done you know and defeat
the criminals and the day would be saved
and that would be about it but that's
why I like this is because it's so much
more grounded once they get in there to
the whole facility in truth Aquaman
shouldn't be here Aquaman should be at
the coastal city that's being threatened
by a massive amount of water but Batman
and his error is exhaustion he's
basically made the wrong call here as
we'll agree though the whole idea behind
this is that Batman makes a call to send
Aquaman back over to the code or sent
him to the coastal city to deal with
that whole scenario and in turn and they
basically bust in and start dealing with
the whole hostage situation now the
problem with this is that the police are
responding at the same time and so of
the Justice League did for the most part
have it under control the cops showing
up out of nowhere and basically raiding
the whole place meant that one of the
guys freaked out they grabbed the sword
of Wonder Woman and they stabbed the nun
through the chest and so one of the
people here is basically killed now at
this point we end up finding out that
what was going on with all those ships
basically going through and looking
around it wasn't really an alien
invasion so much as it was like a
tourist attraction
basically it was people who were going
on this big tour of the galaxy and they
just flew by earth and so it is the
issue here is that in truth had cyborgs
been here like he was supposed to had
Batman taken a scenario as he should
have which is to say basically
contacting the police saying everybody
stand down we've got this or letting the
police you know go in and do their own
thing then this nun wouldn't have died
so people are starting to look at Batman
with a slanted eye essentially saying
hey look this guy's not
Sara Lee making the right kind of
judgment calls we should really question
whether or not this guy is legit now at
this point we sweep back over to the
watchtower you know a little bit after
this whole event events taken place and
of course you end up having like Jessica
Cruz who's walked in on in the John by
just some guy named Glenn Glenn Gamelin
now Glenn Cameron is an old-school DC
character this guy made his appearance
back in 1995 with Justice League task
force and in truth that's what Liza's
why kind of held off on this this is not
Christopher priest first time riding a
Justice League title one of the things
we've talked about in previous videos
was that the Justice League of America
originally appeared back in like 1960
running for about 25 years or so the
Justice League was like DC's role at
least you know they were for time their
premier team eventually the Teen Titans
took over that popularity just because
teenagers love the idea of the Teen
Titans but the fact remains here that in
the post-crisis landscape meaning going
after 1985 running up until 1998 DC had
a whole bunch of Justice League titles
you had Justice League International
which became Justice League Europe you
had Justice League Task Force you had
extreme justice you had a lot of these
different spin-off titles from the main
Justice League team and the whole idea
was to try to see if there was a way to
basically revamp the Justice League team
so that it could in turn become a title
that would promote characters who really
just couldn't hold their own books kind
of become a revolving door for fans to
be introduced to heroes and different
things like that that they wouldn't
normally read now eventually it kind of
became it was really successful at first
but you know once like he's given
basically walked away you know once a
they moved away from the whole thing
what ended up happening is 1998 DC
brought Justice League back with JLA
under Grant Morrison but Christopher
priest was one of the riders who is
contributing to Justice League task
force back during that time now Glen
Cameron's only appeared in like 14
comics so again he's not like a huge
character in the realm of DC he's just a
guy who's there but most of his
escapades out of bounty hunter dealt
with a Martian Manhunter and that's the
reason why when he shows up here he asks
where Martian Manhunter is now this is
where things get a little hairy here we
know Martian Manhunter is back in like
dark nights metal I mean we cover that
you know several weeks ago so we know
Martian Manhunter has returned the
Martian Manhunter being there was part
and parcel to what was going on with
like the Green Lantern Hal Jordan and so
the issue is that when Batman steps up
and says we haven't seen or heard from
Martian Manhunter in quite some time
then again we mean a couple of things
either it means that like Batman knows
about Martian Manhunter being back maybe
they had a run-in of sorts at the end of
Dark Knight's medal we won't know until
that story comes out or Martian
Manhunter his involvement was
isolated to like mr. terrific and Hal
Jordan and like classic man and that's
it like he never returned earth he never
came back to see any other of the other
members of the Justice League they don't
know he's alive and for whatever reason
how Jordan hasn't told them yet mister
terrific hasn't told me we don't really
know I mean we kind of have to just take
this with a grain of salt but what were
you not finding out here and again this
is how each of these stories is kind of
isolated and in sort of continued no
self-contained what we're now finding
out here is there's basically like this
intergalactic cockroach more or less
it's like I said to you cockroach and it
showed up on earth somewhere along the
line and Glen Cameron's been sent as a
bounty hunter to grab this cockroach the
issue with this is that it can procreate
with other cockroaches and in turn
create a kind of hive mind now again
this is a little off the beaten path it
is a little strange remember with Chris
release inaugural run here it's kind of
like hitting all the different fascism
hitting all the different aspects of the
Justice League this is really more of a
throwback to like 1960s Justice League
this is the kind of story you would read
back in the 1960s you know some
intergalactic cockroach with the ability
to like procreate with regular
cockroaches spawns a hive mind and a
giant cockroach thing you know and of
course it really just kind of leads into
the team using a combination of like you
know electromagnetism and a handful of
sound waves and so on to basically
isolate this roach and then of course is
captured by Glenn gamma and there's not
a whole lot to draw from here it's just
kind of a fill-in you know a few set of
events what's a big take away is from
this story is that breaking news I'm
sorry of you know found footage more or
less has basically reached the press and
what this does is it shows the idea that
the nun was killed because of the
intervention of the Justice League
that they jumped in they basically
overruled the cops and in turn it got
this woman killed and so the picture
that's being painted in the eyes of the
general public is that the Justice
League is overstepping its bounds and so
when you have something like the Justice
League which is jumped into you know
some pretty questionable actions in the
past and if you take this as something
that exists is like the aftermath of
dark nights metal mean we've had all of
Metropolis turned into Doomsday's we've
had these evil versions of Batman from
the dark multiverse invading Earth and
attacking all these cities and killing
all these people and suddenly people's
trust in the Justice League begins to
erode
now all of this is compounded by the
fact that there's a woman named named
mrs. Hass Grove who's basically the head
of a commission in Congress this is on a
basically question the Justice League
and see whether or not they are acting
as they're supposed to now if we're
Superman shows up and says hey look this
is everything that's going on and we're
by no means trying to be violent people
so on and so forth this is compounded by
fact that while she's driving she
suddenly meant by the arrival of Batman
who throws a Batarang through her head
and kills her and so again this is crazy
because it starts to go into this idea
that like things are spinning out of
control don't like the Justice League
has taken this sort of dark and you know
evil perspective now this all stems with
the idea that the person you know that
the individual who's Batman is not
actually Bruce Wayne
instead it's basically just a person
they called a fan now this guy's name is
actually Joshua Christian we'll talk
about him here in a second but it's
essentially someone who's obsessed with
the Justice League he's considered to be
a fan he's an extremist and taking out
you know miss Hoffs grofe basically
eliminates this Oversight Committee this
design to monitor the Justice League and
even ask the question should they be
brought in under a special Charter and
controlled by the federal government so
the whole idea is that Batman basically
grabs Simon Simon bast and sends a man
to where this fan is supposed to be
located at under the auspices that Simon
Baskin basically says you know
neutralize him using his ring and so on
and so forth only to be met by the power
of the Black Canary and so this is what
we ended up finding out that this fan
and knows a lot about the Justice League
knows quite a bit and this all stems
back to his early days what we end up
finding out here is that there was a
point in time when the fan was basically
a younger kid and the Justice League was
facing off against shaggy man a
character like doomsday that has the
ability to heal and adapt to attacks and
different things like that but the fan
was watching this whole event unfold and
the fan was basically a huge fan of the
Justice League you know Joshua idolized
them in the extreme he had a troy Green
Lantern rain different things like that
he stood up for people who couldn't
stand up for themselves that was the
whole basis behind it you know his life
led him into the military he was a
person that was always trying to be one
of these individuals who could basically
go on to become what he believed the
Justice League was which is to say
making the world a better place the
problem with this is that in his mind he
has kind of a psychological break he
genuinely believes he's doing the right
thing now the other half of this is that
with Simon Baz being off the radar
there's two things that are basically
going on the first is that you have the
public action of the Justice League
which is to say going on the news and
basically saying hey look here's where
we stand in relation to things one we
don't really have a problem with
individuals who want to help the Justice
League just understand you can't take
the law into your own hands like that
the backside of the justice they kind of
the hidden hand of the Justice League
here is Jessica Cruz going in at the
direction of Batman and trying to locate
Simon dies only to find out the
building's basically been booby-trapped
and so again that's when we end up
learning this guy knows a lot about
Justice League I mean grabbing the whole
idea of some and ask you know
effectively this guy takes the ring of
sama and puts it in a container and says
this thing is designed to keep your ring
in like suspended animation more or less
so that your ring will always try to
escape it won't be able to but it'll
basically drain its power which is kind
of interesting we'll actually find out
more about that here in a second but the
issue with this is that for Simon that
doesn't make any sense the Green Lantern
ring is a product of willpower meaning
that under normal circumstances no one
should be able to take the ring and
basically remove it from a lantern and
then put it in some form of stasis the
lantern can't get to the ring will break
out because it's one of the most
powerful objects in the universe so
Simon Baz realizes two things one the
ring in this container is not this ring
and two the basically sound vibrations
of Black Canary had scrambled his mind
to a degree that he never even realized
his ring was gone or his ring was on his
hand in the first place it's been there
the entire time he just didn't realize
it now again this goes to the extent of
how well this fan knows the various
members of the Justice League jumping in
and then basically neutralizing a Green
Lantern which is no easy feat
impersonating Batman having the physical
prowess to trick people into believing
that he is legitimately Batman that's a
pretty big moment and that's a pretty
big thing but this was designed to
basically lure him out the whole
circumstance so Diana Prince of Wonder
Woman sitting on national TV and saying
look we cannot condone the actions of a
vigilante who would kill people he
doesn't like this because of the fact
that their views are different from his
it was designed to lure out Joshua it
was designed to bring him into the open
and that's exactly what happens but
where the Justice League believes that
on the surface they have him contained
this is where we find out his knowledge
of the Justice League extends
exceedingly farc when we learn that he
has access to the watchtower and
teleports all the members of the Justice
League
across the globe just teleports them to
all these random locations now again
with the fan seemingly making his escape
this really just kind of turns into like
a rounding up trip you know you have
these different things going on rounding
up various people you know so on and so
forth you know grabbing members of
Justice League bringing them all
together but again the whole idea of
this fan is is daunting to Batman he
finds it hard to believe that a member
of the really just like a normal human
out there could basically become so
obsessed with the Justice League he
could in turn become one of the many
individuals who helped to construct the
watchtower thereby learning about all
its security systems he could also
basically impersonate Batman with nobody
really knowing what's going on he could
neutralize all the members of the
Justice League
that's hard press for Batman to believe
now again this is not the first time
something like this has happened and
why it's kind of interesting when it
comes to how your Batman's written in
this situation this is one of those
things where Batman kind of looks around
and says maybe this is my fault like
maybe I am the reason why this is all
screwed up and that's why he starts to
rethink his position in the Justice
League and so while all this is going on
because of the fact of the watchtower
has basically been shut down all of its
systems have been deactivated by it by
Joshua you have the flash they're trying
to get everything back online
but then suddenly the watchtower is met
with a crash which is the result of a
maintenance crew from LexCorp and so
basically almost everyone on this this
maintenance crew seems to have been dead
it seems to have been killed in the
crash except for one guy and of course
where the Justice League shows back up
at the same time they don't realize that
like the flash Barry Allen is out there
in space trying to grab this guy before
he floats off into oblivion and so in
their minds when they show up here it
seems more of like an unmanned ship that
tried to dock itself with the the you
know watchtower and they'll tend to
adhere at a minute all the while not
realizing that Barry Allen's floating
out there in space now the other half of
this is that Barry I was written a
little strange here the way he's written
here is that he basically treated space
like a like like it was just kind of a
getaway you know like you didn't really
matter that much and the reason why this
happens is because he basically uses his
you know it kind of uses a Speed Force
burst to run up on this guy and
inadvertently kind of sparks an electric
static feedback more or less and like
kills this guy in the process but the
whole idea is that Barry kind of looks
around and says well it's my
recklessness that caused this I should
have been a lot more careful but when
you're Barry Allen and you've done
things like travel to other dimensions
or things like that I kind of find it
hard to believe that he wouldn't take
space seriously it's just kind of a
matter of perspective it really just
kind of depends on how you look at it
now this is where things get kind of
crazy instant in the sense of the
Flash's powers I kind of like this it
goes again it's kind of like a throwback
to the old school comics but what is up
happening is crucifer freeze basically
who treats this scenario where Barry
Allen sits down and says okay whenever I
run as the flash I kind of have this
Speed Force aura that protects me now
the Speed Force aura protecting me is
contingent on like you know having an
atmosphere oxygen to breathe and
different things like that and so I'm
willing to bet that I can basically
catapult myself out of here I can take
off back to the watchtower and my speed
force or will protect me for as long as
I can but I should be able to make it
basically Barry Allen runs in space by
running on the little pieces of debris
of the of the ship then you know the the
watchtower that have just kind of spread
all over the place it's a little
questionable at best but this is kind of
like classic 1990 storytelling this is
kind of like classic you know flash
storytelling but a whole aftermath to
this of course Barry Allen's healing
factor will bring
pretty quickly I mean it's not a huge
deal it goes on and you know basically
have the repairs that are being made to
the Justice League Watchtower and so on
but in the aftermath of the whole idea
of the fan and the aftermath of the nun
being killed by the fact that Batman
made the wrong choices what he does is
basically step down from the Justice
League it's also kind of weird that
Jessica Cruz kisses him it's kind of
weird considering they're like he's
engaged to two Selina Kyle but I always
had a feeling that Bruce Wayne was never
really like a one-woman bat you know
what I mean like Mike you know he's like
hey look you know I mean Selina Kyle I
love you to death like you know we'll be
together forever but like until that
ring goes on your finger woman like I'm
out there I mean I'd like to think
Batman to be more honorable than to like
you know step out on Selina Kyle which I
don't know why you would man like she's
super hot but the fact remains here the
Batman as he's leaving basically chooses
a successor usually sits down and says
someone has to be the leader of the
Justice League
and according to arch harder I have the
right to select who the new Chairman is
going to be and under normal
circumstances we would expect Superman
the last person I would expect is cyborg
and that's what's so interesting about
this is you know Batman chooses cyborg
to be the new leader of the Justice
League now what this means is actually
covered in justice Lost you know when
the next story arc that follows after
this which is currently ongoing it's not
finished yet but if you guys are new
here two comments explain make sure you
guys to the sub button to become part of
the robb core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace